en 2021 recibió el premio fil de
literatura en lenguas romances en la
feria del libro de guadalajara
se encuentra en argentina donde
participó en la feria del libro de
buenos aires de la charla la literatura
como forma de resistencia le damos la
bienvenida a la escritora chilena
diamela eltit gracias por acompañarnos
en france 24 en español muchas gracias
por la invitación la literatura como
forma de resistencia resistir que
y cómo
si en realidad es como formas de
resistencias en el sentido de que no hay
una sola tu tienes que resistir
al vacío de la página al vacío de la
escritura que siempre está alrededor
tuyo no entonces eso es un riesgo que se
produzca ese vacío es esa no escritura
en un deseo de escritura no esa es una
cuestión más o menos común que afecta al
campo literario y por otro lado está
digamos las condiciones en las que se
escribe las condiciones sociales
entendiendo que los escritores y
escritoras en general tienen
dificultades por ejemplo para sostenerse
lo que hace no es es otro problema es
como escribir con algo que no te permite
vivir a diferencia de otro oficio donde
si eso es posible
y tienes también por ejemplo en mi caso
particular yo escribí bajo dictadura y
mis libros tenían que pasar por una
oficina de censura entonces en ese
sentido también hay otro punto donde
está enfrentado al sensor en el caso de
la dictadura y por otro lado también la
literatura puede esbozar relatos
y expongan
su énfasis en denunciar ciertas
situaciones y esa capacidad también la
tienen todos los discursos públicos los
discursos estéticos y entre ellos la
literatura entonces hay muchas
resistencias por otro lado no pienso que
en contenidos resistentes necesariamente
no porque efectivamente están las
metáforas y las poéticas a mí me
interesa generar digamos las literaturas
que generan poéticas y que por lo tanto
invocan al lector un proceso no no es
solamente la literatura como en su
atención sino también la lectura como
trabajo me viene a la mente una cosa que
contó de cuando ustedes estaban
participando de un grupo de acciones de
arte en el chile de la dictadura y de
salían a ser pintadas que decían nomás
con una especie de juego de cadáver
exquisito esperando que se complete por
parte de la sociedad un no más dictadura
no más opresión
pensando en esa provocación que pone en
la letra impresa es más larga y más
compleja hay uno más
diferente hoy en chile no más que
pues de chile ya nombró muchos no más
prácticamente no más todo que era en
definitiva un no a un sistema muy
opresivo y muy discriminado porque el
sistema neoliberal no donde la
democracia está formulada del mercado
del mercado es el centro de la
democracia entonces vivimos un estallido
social de proporciones de verdad que fue
una micro revolución muy poderosa muy
incesante que sólo fue interrumpido por
la enfermedad no incluso todavía puede
haber son las larvarias de esa crisis
entonces éste
efectivamente a lo que tú te refieres
que me parece muy interesante
las calles se hicieron sede de novelas
el estallido generó personajes
como el perro mata paco en fin una serie
de personas que concurrieron y se
escribieron como grafitis y como
escenografías en las calles entonces ahí
hubo una novela que todavía está escrita
si tú vas ante algo la puedes leer y ahí
había digamos ese nomás no esté impreso
con sus personajes que actúan incluso la
poeta gabriela mistral
apareció como un personaje en los muros
un personaje que resistía en este caso
según lo fue dibujaron en la revuelta
desde el feminismo
entonces ahí están esos personajes esa
novela está en la calle y es visible
para toda persona que transite por
santiago y también en provincia
muchas gracias no gracias a ustedes
gracias por acompañarnos también aquí en
france24 en español los invitamos a
seguir con nuestra programación
y a ver nuestros contenidos en france 24
punto com